Harry Kersh: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between UK and US Starbucks.
This is "Food Wars."
Now, hot coffees in the
UK come in four sizes.
Firstly, we have a short coffee,
which is 8 ounces.
Joe Avella: The short, 8 ounces.
Harry: Then we have a tall
coffee, which is 12 ounces.
Joe: Next we have the tall, 12 ounces.
Harry: Next is a grande coffee,
which comes in at 16 ounces.
Joe: Then we got the grande, 16 ounces.
Harry: A venti, or 20 ounces.
Joe: Sensational.
And the biggest one, the venti, 20 ounces.
And in case you're wondering,
it's called the venti
because 20 in Italian is venti-twento.
Harry: Just to double-check,
we're gonna measure the
largest hot coffee in the UK.
So, our venti coffee actually
came to closer to 18 ounces.
Sort that out, Starbucks.
Where's my 2 ounces?
Joe: Now I'm going to
measure the venti coffee,
which should be 20
ounces minus a few sips.
Wait.
Came prepared.
Whoa, come on! I did not drink that much.
Oh, Starbucks.
That's not...no, that's not even two.
That's, like, an ounce.
Harry: Cold coffees in the
UK come in three sizes.
A tall.
Joe: The tall, 12 ounces.
Harry: Grande.
Joe: We got the grande.
Harry: And venti.
Joe: Here's where things
get kind of weird.
Our venti iced is 24 ounces.
And we have another
size up, trenti, right?
Trenta, and that is 30 ounces.
Harry: So, a UK cold venti
is exactly 20 ounces.
Joe: Yeah, 21.
I thought this was supposed to be 24.
"How many fluid ounces
venti iced"?
24.
How much is it, 21?
Starbucks, with the ice,
you still don't have enough.
Aah. I'm taking a sip
of every single drink.
I'm taking a sip of every single drink!
Let's do this!
Harry: Let's compare some
seemingly identical drinks
to see how much they
match up under the hood.
So, a venti latte in the UK
contains 235 calories,
7.9 grams of fat,
21.1 grams of sugar,
and 225 milligrams of caffeine.
Joe: And in the US,
the same venti latte has 250 calories,
and that's 9 grams of fat
and 150 milligrams of caffeine.
And you know I'm taking a sip.
Mm!
Kind of cold. It's been
sitting out for hours.
So our latte's got more sugar,
more calories, and more fat.
"The trinity of deliciousness"
is what I call it.
Harry: Let's try something
a little heavier.
If you were to order a
venti caramel Frappuccino
from a UK Starbucks,
it would contain 426 calories,
61.1 grams of sugar,
and 117 milligrams of caffeine.
Joe: Harry, your Frappuccino's
looking a little sad there, buddy.
It looks like all your
whipped cream melted,
so here's a pro tip from the USA.
Mm.
470 calories,
74 carbs, 73 of which are sugar,
and 120 milligrams of caffeine.
Mm.
Damn. Oh, yuck. Yuck!
That's what that tastes like?
Harry: Now, it's
important to remember that
for cold drinks like Frappuccinos,
the US venti is actually
4 fluid ounces larger
than the UK's.
If you were to do the math to work out
the nutrition per fluid ounce,
the UK actually beats the US
in virtually every metric.
Let's see if we can
get any clues as to why
from the ingredients.
Now, in the UK, a
cappuccino from Starbucks
contains just two ingredients,
milk and brewed espresso.
Joe: And in the US, our
cappuccinos are made
from milk and brewed espresso.
Look at that. Same thing, finally.
Mm. Mm!
Harry: Now, for the most part,
the hot coffees in both countries
are just those two ingredients
in different quantities.
Things get a little bit more complicated
once you start to add
things like syrups, however.
For example, in the UK,
if you add caramel syrup
to your cappuccino,
that adds the following ingredients:
sugar, water, natural flavoring,
concentrate of apple, carrot, hibiscus,
molasses, citric acid,
and potassium sorbate.
Joe: Aah.
Whereas our caramel syrup has sugar,
corn syrup, butter (cream (milk) salt),
uh, water, heavy cream,
nonfat dry milk,
natural flavors, salt,
mono diggly-psoriasis?
I don't know what that word is.
Soy lecithin and sulfites.
The point is, our caramel
syrup has actual caramel in it.
How do you like that?
Harry: Now let's try something
with a lot more ingredients.
This is a java chip
Frappuccino from the UK,
and it contains the following.
Both: Ice.
Milk.
Coffee Frappuccino syrup,
Harry: Which is water --
Joe: Which is sugar, water --
[both reciting different ingredients]
[fast-forwarding]
Harry: Sodium bicarbonate
Joe: Sodium
Harry: and a mocha drizzle,
Joe: bi-cow-bonate,
Harry: which is water,
Harry: mocha powder, sugar,
Joe: Soy lecithin,
Harry: cocoa processed with
Joe: natural flavors,
Harry: alkaline, and vanillin.
Joe: oh, and salt.
Ladies and gentlemen, it
is a "Food Wars" first,
the first time something in the UK
has an ingredients list longer
than something in the US.
Time to celebrate, baby!
[party horn blowing]
Harry: Here is everything
you can only find on the menu
at a UK Starbucks.
Joe: And this is everything
you can get in a US Starbucks.
Harry: Now, we'll start
with a quick disclaimer.
One of the big selling points of Starbucks
is that you can heavily customize
pretty much everything on the menu.
To save ourselves doing
a million different
combinations of exclusive items,
what we're gonna do is focus mostly
on things that are on
the menu as they are,
with just a few combinations
of syrups and toppings
that you can get in one or the other.
Firstly, we have this cute little cortado.
Secondly, we have a cold foam cappuccino,
which is like an iced cappuccino
with just some foam on top of it.
Then we have some temporary
season exclusives.
So, at the moment, you can get a
peanut butter cup Frappuccino in the UK,
as well as a chocolate
s'mores Frappuccino,
which sounds pretty damn good.
Joe: In the US, along with the blond roast
you can get in the UK, we
also have a dark roast,
and we have something
called the Pike Place roast.
And that roast is a tribute
to the first Starbucks
that's near the Pike Place
Market in Seattle, Washington.
I've been to that Starbucks.
It's fine.
Exclusive to the US, we have
the caramel cloud macchiato.
Ooh, I do not like that.
The mocha cookie crumble Frappuccino.
Woof.
The caramel ribbon crunch Frappuccino.
I mean, the regular caramel one was gross.
Let's see how this one is.
Oh, God, it's worse.
Oh, it's so much worse.
And we also have this,
a vanilla sweet cream cold brew.
The ice has melted.
Woof.
I bet that was good six
hours ago when it was made.
Harry: And what we've done is combined
as many UK exclusives as
we can into one drink,
which I'm calling the UK Only.
We've got some almond,
some sugar-free caramel,
some sugar-free hazelnut, and some mango,
which is gonna be an interesting mix.
Hoo!
That is sweet.
[laughs]
Joe: And of course at
the Starbucks in the US,
we have our own unique customizations.
For instance, pineapple ginger syrup,
raspberry syrup, toffee nut syrup,
a cascara topping,
cinnamon dolce sprinkles.
We have chocolate, cinnamon,
nutmeg, and vanilla powders
and a whole range of cold foams.
So, of course, I went ahead
and had all those things
put into one drink,
which I am calling the USA Only.
Mm-mm.
Oh, man, that's weird.
Nothing in that works together.
Mm.
[ambient music]
[echoes] That caffeine's
starting to hit, baby.
It's starting to hit!
[party horn blowing]
[ambient music continues]
[tapping table]
Starbucks. [laughs]
Harry: Now, this series
isn't called "Drink Wars,"
and thankfully Starbucks
has lots of food items.
Here are some things you'll only find
on the menu at a UK Starbucks.
Let's start with the bakery section.
Here in the UK, on the bakery menu,
you will find a chocolate
chunk shortbread cookie.
You will find this delightful
little gingerbread barista man.
You will find this pain aux raisins.
We also have some luxury fruit toast,
which comes with these
little cute pots of jam.
And then finally we've
got a cinnamon swirl,
which is kind of just a cinnamon roll.
Our breakfast options
are slightly limited.
Most of what we have is a
range of breakfast rolls,
which is just kind of like a
breakfast sandwich in the UK,
but served on crusty white bread.
Some options include a bacon sandwich.
Bacon sandwiches are a
pretty big deal over here.
[slo-mo] I like mine with ketchup.
And then also, if you want
something a little bit more,
you can go for an all-day
breakfast sandwich,
which is bacon, sausage,
and egg all in one roll.
Joe: Here are all the
US-exclusive food items.
So, a lot of different breakfast
sandwiches for Starbucks.
This one right here is
the Impossible meat sandwich.
Spinach, egg, and feta cheese wrap.
This is my go-to one. Love it.
These egg bites, these little, um,
gonna definitely pronounce this wrong,
these little sood-vee egg wraps. Sood vee?
I'll be straight up, I've
never had one of these.
Holy s---, these are so good.
Oh, my God!
A lot of baked goods, like
this little friendly guy,
just in time for the holiday season,
a little snowman cake pop.
Bunch of different
varieties of sugar cookies.
I got this one 'cause I
think it looks the nicest,
but I don't want this at all.
Oh, but you know what I do love?
Dude. Danishes, especially
cheese danishes.
We also got scones.
So I'm going with the blueberry scone.
Can we get Harry's face on there?
Scone Harry?
Harry: Sorry to break it to you, Joe,
but that is not a scone.
Few things to point out.
Firstly, it's pronounced skahn, not skohn.
Secondly, they should all --
Joe: The marshmallow dream bar,
aka a rice crispy treat.
What are we doing?
We're going to Starbucks in the morning,
and we're getting cookies
and rice crispy treats for breakfast?
No, no.
They got bagels.
I asked for cream cheese, and they forgot.
Pumpkin cream cheese muffin.
It's got pumpkin,
a little glob of cream
cheese in it right there.
Muffins are OK in the morning.
I'm pro morning muffin.
Last and probably least
because I've never had one,
nor have I ever wanted one,
Starbucks in the US have a lot
of what they call protein boxes.
Chicken and quinoa.
Looks like a salad.
Harry: You guys have pretty
much all the lunch options
that we have, in terms of, like,
paninis, sandwiches, and wraps.
One thing I did wanna highlight was this,
which is a cheese and
Marmite mini ciabatta.
So, Marmite, as some of you will know,
is a spread that's
quite popular in the UK.
It's like the byproduct of making beer.
When the yeast ferments,
it kind of leaves, like,
a sludge on the bottom of the tank.
And that is Marmite.
But it somehow tastes really good.
Joe: Harry, no to Marmite.
It's bad, stop it.
Harry: So, on top of classic
English breakfast tea,
we also have some
exclusive teas to the UK.
So, we'll start with the
jasmine pearl green tea,
which is just our exclusive
version of the green tea.
Here we've got something
called a youthberry tea,
which apparently helps keep you young.
Here is some chamomile tea,
which is great if you just want something
to relax before bed.
Then we've got some frozen teas as well.
So, this is a frozen iced
tea made with apple and kiwi.
This is a frozen iced
tea with tropical mango.
And then this is a frozen
strawberry and lime tea.
Joe: Here in the US, we have
a lot of exclusive teas too.
These are those exclusive teas.
For hot ones, we have a jade citrus mint,
a peach tranquility tea.
Think they missed a trick there,
not calling it the peach tranquili-tea.
[audience cheering]
Conner Blake came up with that, not me.
The revved up tea right there.
And then for the cold ones,
we got the royal English breakfast tea.
Why don't you guys have the
iced royal English breakfast tea?
A matcha lemonade tea,
a iced guava black tea,
and the passion tango iced tea.
Mm, mm, mm!